well guys another day another influencer
scam
this time from none other than logan
paul
yes that's right folks i also thought he
had enough money from boxing with floyd
mayweather to where he wouldn't need to
promote
an outright scam but he did anyways
let's go to the board and check it out
ladies and gentlemen welcome to the 10
million dollar studio i'm your host
coffee zilla the internet detective and
today
we're talking about the logang guys you
forget about this guy
uh he's been doing making big waves
making fights
making bank but not enough bank because
he's recently endorsed
a crypto coin called dink doink
i'm doing the same thing as you holding
my doink now dink doink
is one of many tokens with zero actual
usefulness instead like every other
ponzi token
it's built off nothing but marketing
hype a few celebrity shout outs
and the eventual sell-off that's gonna
happen
and here's the honorable logan paul to
promote his ponzi scheme
what up dink doing telegram it's me
logan paul
now i know what you're thinking logan
what the [ __ ] are you doing here
i'm doing the same thing as you holding
my doink
that's what i'm doing this is a point i
believe in y'all actually
this is something okay dude this is
something everyone's been doing lately
they think like to themselves
maybe if i run a ponzi scheme ironically
it will be forgiven right like maybe if
we just lean into the fact that
everyone knows it's a scam i can then
scam
and it's okay because hey guys we're
being ironic about the fact
that it's a [ __ ] coin no self-awareness
doesn't save you
congratulations you're a piece of trash
who knows you're a piece of trash good
good job buddy good job it's my favorite
one to be honest
ding dong is so much more than a meme
coin it's a multimedia coin
cartoon meets crypto it's the blockchain
baby
in in in cartoon fun comedy format
i'm gonna be doing an episode myself
soon okay so he promotes it he says
there's gonna be
um that's a big thing there's gonna be
cartoons involved but it looks like
they're trying to rip off the
the south park style and in general he
presents himself as like an
interested but unaffiliated investor
in this coin saying this is the dumbest
most ridiculous
coin i've ever seen and that's why i'm
all in but it turns out
this is incredibly misleading because
logan paul is far from just a guy who
found out about this coin like anyone
else because in a podcast with the dink
doing ceo
he said that logan paul created the
thing we might as well you know
be be honest about how this came about i
was chilling with logan
and and we were like what's the
stupidest name we could think of
for like a coin right what's the
weirdest name we could think of for like
a little mascot that's like a dumb
spring we're like dink joint oh my god
his name's dink doink
and it just came alive like logan
designed the
character on his phone on snapchat so
you design it and then you go wow this
is the coolest thing i've ever seen
it's your thing like what you don't
think you should mention the fact that
you designed the thing that you're the
guy
who designed the whole like mascot idea
i mean take credit for your idea
if you thought of it take credit but i
think he doesn't want to because
obviously it looks bad if you're pumping
your own little ponzi coin you created
and it's not just logan paul the whole
gang's here the whole impulsive gangs
here
look at this it's disgusting promoting
this to your fans
hey guys what's up it's me mike
here to send some love and camaraderie
to the
dink doing telegram team i know you guys
have been busting your ass to make sure
that the hottest newest coin how is this
not parody
how are you able to look at yourself in
the mirror and not be
embarrassed by this performance here wha
what
what am i watching 2021 is dink doink
with the hottest functionality and all
of the most built-in
techniques tactics and capabilities
it's funny because he's like saying it
like he's being sarcastic but there is
no turn in this video where he's like
i'm just joking guys
i wouldn't promote upon he's like trying
to ironically do it
but also he's serious dink doink is
cleared to be the hottest
[ __ ] coin ever here's their other
buddy okay
you've got uh all-star cast of logan
paul universe
a dwarf mama here to tell you
each and every one of you is beautiful
you know why you know why
because y'all are part y'all are making
me rich
i got in early and you're pumping my
bags that's how this works guys
they get in early you pump up their bags
they sell it off of one of the greatest
if not
the greatest coin of all time
of all time i love how they all pretend
like this isn't their little house's
idea
they were all sitting in the house they
thought of this idea and they have some
other guy launch it who's like an
unknown this guy
jake he's not very well known but they
actually are the ones who thought of and
they promote it like it's not their
thing
dink doink is going to the [ __ ] moon
you don't believe me you don't have to
you can just be
naive and dumb it's all good uh i don't
think we're the naive
dumb ones here okay but y'all
the community we're not naive we're not
dumb
[ __ ] family oh hey you're not even
dumb if you believe that
that you're a a family right when they
sell off they're going to be your family
try calling them and going hey i lost
the house i'm on dink doing see what
this guy
mister were family says to you then oh
my god this is such a disingenuous
little scheme created by the low gang
unbelievable even the founder was asked
about like dude why is this
even a coin in the first place and he
could hardly answer it you know
as you well know there's over ten
thousand
uh cryptos out there right now uh what
makes your project different from the um
countless amounts of bses that launch
every day pay attention
good question what a great question um
thanks for that question specifically
because it's like the most important
question right
i've never been asked that question this
is actually my first podcast
okay dude what is this answer the
stalling
hey that's such a great question really
great question and i'm going to answer
that question this is my first podcast
ever
guy you don't have it thanks for that
question specifically because it's like
the most important question right i've
never been asked that question this is
actually my first
podcast okay as dink doing so
okay i have a really good answer to it
all right it's been 30 seconds get to
the answer
logan paul wanted more money that's ding
ding ding
hey you got yourself an answer baby
that's your answer logan paul wanted
more money
but sorry go ahead i'm i'm doing this
for for
a very specific purpose and dink doing
on its face is a funny cartoon and it's
a meme
and it's a community having fun on
twitter
and it's social media stars tweeting
about it every week
and you know that's what it is on its
face
what happens with the social media stars
stop tweeting about it by the way
you ever ask yourself that you got a few
people to tweet while it makes the money
what happens when this thing inevitably
loses steam
it went from going up to going down
and what goes up must come down so if
you guys made a million dollars off this
you've taken a million dollars from your
fans congratulations you've reinvented a
ponzi game
great job guys you know you brought up
bitcoin earlier
and and what's going on with elon and
those two communities now in sort of a
coral
and i i find the crypto space in this
moment to be
at at its most important moment it's
ever had where
community turns into need at some point
to move forward
we have the technology we have the
attention we have the passion
we have everything except a useful coin
that people
actually want to use so you're gonna
solve that by creating
dink doink except
a unified community the need of
cryptocurrency
is a unified community you're saying and
your solution
to a fractured community with too many
coins is to create
another coin this is the dumbest thing
i've ever seen
and the only explanation is a blatant
cash grab this coin has no usefulness
outside of a few celebrities talking
about it and it's supposed to be like
about comedy and fun
but really at the end of the day this is
just an investment
a very bad investment that is clearly
going to enrich
a few people at the cost of everyone
else and the last thing i want to show
you to prove that
is uh the fact that 80 of the these
coins are currently owned by the top
100 wallets okay guys if you want to buy
dink doink you can go check out who owns
all the coins
and right now the top 100 holders of
whom you can be certain logan paul
and the gang or some of them own 80 of
this thing
and you're telling me that this is gonna
revolutionize and change the world
no i don't think so it's just another
scam from another
celebrity influencer who's pretending to
be ironically doing it
it's embarrassing logan paul designed
this whole thing he needs to actually
stand by this coin instead of pretending
to be some
outside sort of oh i think it's a fun
coin you designed it
duh you know don't be like that these
influencers need to pay for this stuff
it's so disgusting they use their fans
like piggy banks and i for one am tired
of it
anyways that's basically it i hope you
enjoyed this little review of dink doink
the new scam coin logan paul's been
promoting
thanks for watching and i'll see you
next
lost time wake up you smell the coffee